so this is an actual problem from an
American textbook since many students
struggle with the order of operations
let's figure it out what is 24 divided
by 12 divided by 2 multiplied by 5. by
the way this is a multiplication dot so
I will replace it with the time symbol
so people aren't confused
I asked this question on Twitter and
many people showed that their calculator
gave the answer a 5 and that is the
correct answer so why is that let's go
through it we'll use the order of
operations in this expression we have
Division and multiplication so we'll
work from left to right
first we have 24 divided by 12 which is
equal to 2 then we have 2 divided by 2
which is equal to 1 and finally one
times five gives the correct answer of
5.